you know Bud Light they pretend that
they learn their lesson transheiser Bush
they pretend that they okay we're sorry
well we're not exactly sorry but we're
gonna back off the Dylan Mulvaney stuff
we're not going to push the trans stuff
too much hey come on we're just gonna
have commercials of horses and cowboys
now please buy our beer again but then
at the same time Bud Light is currently
sponsoring an all ages drag event in
Flagstaff Arizona
it's going to happen on June 17th this
was reported first by the Washington
Free Beacon
it was then
republished in the Washington examiner
it's it's happening
it's unclear how many drag queens will
be performing nine drag queens were
featured on the flyer
attendees who are miners are more than
welcome to come in if you're 15 years
old or older no but you just walk right
in no problem at all
if you're under 15 you can still come in
you just need to be accompanied by a
parent or a guardian according to the
flyer so it's for kids it's for
everybody that's transheiser Bush
totally unrepentant we've done a good
job really weakening them I mean they've
lost well over 20 billion in market cap
that's great news the only thing that's
going to work here those political
intervention because transheiser bush is
caught between a rock and a hard place
because transheiser bush has signed on
to all sorts of agreements that are
across corporations across Industries
across countries which say that they're
going to promote Pride as the new
established religion of liberalism
they're going to promote it
and so if they don't promote it if they
turn against it they're going to lose
access to social media platforms they're
going to lose access to other
advertising platforms they're going to
lose access to Capital because the asset
managers are pushing this stuff so what
is required here is not just
all of us together in a Grassroots way
stop stopping our consumption of
Bud Light and transcise Bush products we
need our elected officials to go in and
intervene and break up these Pride
cartels that are pushing garm you know
the the big
Pro
liberalism you know pro-leftism uh uh
organization that's now under the world
economic Forum Banner or ESG
environmental social governance policies
and all the rest of it we need the heavy
hand of the state to go in as our duly
elected representatives and break up
that Pride cartel right now go to
hallow.com it is very clear that the
libs are giving up their morals and
common sense if they ever had any there
is no better time to build a daily habit
of prayer and meditation building a
habit of prayer can help you cultivate
an attitude of gratitude focusing on
what you were thankful for can increase
positive emotions and increase overall
well-being hello is the number one
Christian Prayer app in the United
States it has helped a lot of people
maintain a daily prayer routine it can
help you too download the app for free
at hallow.com Knowles kwles you can set
prayer reminders and track your progress
along the way are you not sure where to
start well check out father Mike
schmitz's Bible in a year my favorite
podcast available on the Hallow app for
brief daily readings and Reflections or
prey alongside Mark Wahlberg Jim
Caviezel and even some world-class
athletes not myself included not yet at
least with hallow you can customize a
personal prayer plan that works for you
listen wherever you are with
downloadable offline sessions using
hallow to connect with others who share
your beliefs and values can provide a
sense of belonging support and Foster a
sense of community ultimately we will
learn how we can become better people in
spite of today's broken World As We
strive to become more like Christ in our
daily lives to prayer fasting and giving
download Hello at hello.com Knowles get
an exclusive three months free three
months absolutely free at hallow.com
Knowles
now speaking of the heavy-handed the
state
we had a new presidential candidate in
the race
I know you're thinking of a bunch of
names oh is he talking about this new
presidential candidate or This I Promise
You
you're not thinking of the man that I'm
about to name
now it would be North Dakota governor
Doug burgum are you feeling the bergam
momentum are you taken away governor
I grew up in a tiny town in North Dakota
woke was what you did at 5am to start
the day
[Music]
a place where neighbors rally around you
my mom
was our Rock our hero
I started a shoe shine business
worked at the grain elevator
and has a chimney sweep
[Music]
paid my way through college then earned
an MBA from Stanford
[Music]
I ignored those who said North Dakota
was too small too cold and too remote to
build a world-class software company
in North Dakota something about
who grew up in I had a software company
um
what
what are you going to do if you're
president
America's facing new challenges and how
we respond will Define our future
[Music]
we need new leadership for our changing
economy
Innovation over regulation
instead of shutting down American Oil
and Gas we should unleash energy
production and start selling energy to
our allies instead of buying it from our
enemies
high taxes red tape and inflation are
choking every American
as Governor we cut red tape and took
North Dakota from billions in the hole
to a surplus
we balanced the budget every year and we
did it all while passing the largest tax
cuts in North Dakota history a smart guy
who's achieved a lot
Doug burgum for president
a new leader for a changing economy
he seems like a nice guy so I don't want
to be too harsh about this campaign ad
and this I mean I already fell asleep
during it so I guess I'm being a little
bit harsh
this ain't it
whatever it is right now this ad and
candidacy ain't it and you see it right
there at the very end Doug burgum new
leadership for a changing economy
economy
are we
an economy with a nation attached to it
or are we a nation with an economy
do we exist here in America
so that we can serve the economy
and markets and GDP or do we have
prosperity and GDP and markets and
everything to serve us the American
people is the nation more than just the
economy yeah for the 90s for a lot of
the 2000s we were told that
the whole point of government is just so
that we can make a little bit more money
that the nation is nothing more than
that people who happen to be living next
to one another so that we can all just
make more money separately but you know
I guess we'll have we'll have to have
some bare minimum regulations so that we
can continue to exist in physical
proximity to one another but all we are
really here to do is worship at the
altar of the free market and that has
led to Absolute chaos such that now
between America and our neighbor up in
up in the north which is giving us
plumes of smoke right now and is a
crystal ball into America's future we
are killing babies
we're killing our children we're killing
our elderly we're killing our poor we're
killing our homeless because they're not
productive they're kind of inconvenient
they're not going to serve the economy
we are chopping off people's genitals
we're creating a generation of eunuchs
and uh well frankly one of the reasons
we're doing it is so that scam companies
like folks and plume can make some money
so the big Pharma can make some money so
that even the whole system will create
more perfect consumers who don't who
don't worry about these extra things
like family and raising children and all
sorts of non-economic considerations but
they just exist out there to keep on
working good little worker bees who
aren't going to have to worry about any
of those things we've destroyed the
family we've destroyed our borders in
part so that we can import more workers
and make more money you heard that
I don't know just this strict focus on
the economy hasn't served us well it
hasn't even served our economy which is
on the brink of collapse boy what a
great clip that was make sure you ring
that Bell subscribe to the Michael
Knowles YouTube channel we'll see you
next time